Reverend Billy Graham may have been the
most successful Christian evangelist
since st. Paul it's difficult to gauge
the enormity of the impact made by the
man who died today at age 99 in 2007
Graham's organization estimated they had
preached the gospel to more than 215
million people in more than 185
countries and territories over 60 years
that doesn't include the hundreds of
millions more he reached through
television through video and film
religion without a personal encounter
with Jesus Christ will not save the soul
and it will not bring the peace that
your soul longs for I know that God has
sent me out as a warrior on the five
continents to preach the gospel and I
must continue until he gives the signal
that I'm to stop if you remember nothing
that I say tonight except one thing I
want you to remember joining us now to
discuss Graham's legacy is an absolute
all-star panel of religious leaders in
Lake Forest California Pastor Rick
Warren of the Saddleback Church in
Virginia Beach dr. Pat Robertson from
the Christian Broadcasting Network and
in Fort Myers Florida tholian Chavez in
it was a grandson of Reverend Graham
gentlemen it's great to see all of you
on this sad night look what a wonderful
night to reflect an amazing man and Rick
Warren I'd like to start with you
because I know that Reverend Graham was
a mentor to you you've known him for
years
tell us about him the man and the
influence on you personally well as you
said Laura Billy Graham was the most
influential Christian of the 20th
century nobody comes close to speaking
in history to 200 million people face to
face and only Pope John Paul the second
and mother Teresa would be as widely
known around the world as Billy was
growing up in a Baptist home Billy
Graham was our Pope and I read my first
Billy Graham book peace with God I think
when I was in the sixth grade at 17 I
heard him for the first time when was
thrilled at the Oakland cruise
and at 20 I met him person to person at
the la crusade and began a 20-year relay
for two year relationship where he
mentored me over the last 40 years did
he get you through the good times and
the bad did you seek counsel from him
Reverend Warren when you you know you
needed it most well you know one of the
greatest things about Billy
that people don't know is that he was an
encourage to the next generation and
I've actually tried to learn from him on
that a lot of stuff that he taught me
I've done with the next generation
myself and one of them was he provided
platforms for younger people I remember
when I was up in high school no college
I wrote my first book on how to study
the Bible methods and I wasn't a very
confident writer at all but the Billy
Graham believed in me and somehow he got
a copy of a book that I had
self-published he called me in the
mid-80s and said Rick I'm bringing
13,000 evangelists to Amsterdam for 10
days of training and I want you to come
and train them and teach them how to
study the Bible I'm in Lenny's
Wow he says I bought a copy of your book
in 17 languages 17 languages and I want
you to come teach him that's how much he
believed in young people and you know
I've you know he's helped me ever since
he and through coaching through you know
doing the inauguration prayer for
President Bush and then for President
Obama the advice he gave me behind the
scenes was invaluable Wow Reverend
Robertson I need to I need to hear from
you on this because you have been
friends with Reverend Graham for many
decades he spoke so highly of you over
the years and he said just this was back
in 2002 he talked about death something
we all face and I want to play it for
you let's listen I remember one night in
the hospital two nights in hospital I
thought I was dying
and my whole life came before me I said
Oh Lord I'm a sinner I still need your
forgiveness I still need the cross and I
asked and I asked the Lord to give me
peace in my heart and he did a wonderful
piece that hasn't left me till this day
and that's been nearly 2 years ago
Reverend Robertson your comment on that
he emanated that sense of peace and a
resolute clarity you know what are the
thing that was so striking of but Billy
grandma we were friends you know I was a
head of the college follow up in his New
York crusade in 57 so we go back oh ha
and he is a man whose humble that
statement was so humble I need God's
forgiveness he always talked about the
cross he never took authority for
himself he was the friend of presidents
one after the other
he led people to the Lord by the
hundreds of thousands he was acclaimed
you know man of the year time and time
again always humility always I've got to
seek the cross of Jesus he always
pointed people with Jesus and a way for
himself that's the thing that struck his
to me and I was with him at the fall of
the Berlin Wall I mean he came to
dedicate this building I'm in right now
he's a dear dear friend for many years
and but always humbled never ever did he
take any heirs to himself that he was
some kind of a hotshot and he was he was
he is the preeminent evangelical in the
world and if we've got 50 million
evangelicals in America he was number
one everybody looked to him everybody
admired him and if he if we wanted to
get something done we said let's get
Billy had to hit it up and things we got
to get done Julian your grandfather you
said that you didn't really realize
until you were you know a little bit
older just how important he was because
of why
Rick and Pat just said his deep sense of
humility which was so attractive and
soap humility is powerful and I thought
it was so powerful in him hmm yeah it
was and I think as one of his grandsons
we got to see a perspective we got to
see him in ways that no one else got to
see him and I can tell you that the
humility that the public saw we saw in
private I mean he is genuinely the most
humble person I have ever met in my life
and I remember asking him one time daddy
bill that's what we called him daddy
bill and I said daddy bill how in the
world have you remained so humble in
light of all of your accomplishments and
in light of all of the adulation and
praise that you receive and he looked at
me kind of puzzled he didn't like the
fact that I even said he was humble
because he did not think he was humble
at all but he said you know it's hard to
be proud when you begin each day with
God when you begin each day with God you
realize that God is big and I am small
God is God and I am not so I think it
was even for us family members it was
really his humility that left the most
deepest impression on all of us but it
was also his message I think Laura one
of the things that separates him from so
many different religious leaders even
Christian leaders is the idea that he
preached so passionately the idea that
the essence the foundation of
Christianity is not what we do for God
it's what God in Christ has done for us
and I think that is a huge huge thing to
say that it was all about Christ's
finished work on our behalf that we
don't have to add to what God has
already done for us that God has already
granted us his approval in his
acceptance and his love because of what
Jesus has done for us and so you know
the man of course is just you know
speaks volumes his humility his
faithfulness his devotion he was a
family man he was keenly devoted to his
family but then his message really his
message I think stands out Julie and I
have
I have a kind of an odd question what's
he funny did he have a I know a pat will
know this but the sense of humor because
he o seems like most the times so
serious and he's so black as it was
black and white is like we're but I love
that it was so powerful but was he funny
they do frown well yeah I think the
funniest part about daddy bill is that
he didn't realize he was funny that was
the funny thing is that I think we spent
most of our time laughing at him rather
than laughing though he was sort of
unconsciously humorous but he had a
remarkable sense of humor and here's one
other thing too he he took God very
seriously but he never ever took himself
too seriously and I think that gave him
a humaneness that was very very
relatable to all of us Rick on today's
world it's it's a broken world that's
always been broken but lately we really
seem more than I remember to be at each
other's throats it's hard to have civil
conversations and people about politics
people take things out of context people
who are friends are not talking because
of politics
what would Reverend Graham say to that
because he stayed away from politics he
was friends with everybody but what
would he say about the the tone and the
rancor today especially well one of the
hallmarks of Billy was not just the
humility that tolian and Pat mentioned
but it was his integrity also he was
spotless after 60 years and third third
would be he was a uniter he was a
builder a bridge builder people forget
that in the 50s and in the 60s Billy
Graham insisted that all of his
campaigns and Crusades in the south
be integrated and for many of those
southern cities they were the first
publicly integrated events in those
cities when Billy Graham came to town
and he said I'm not coming unless
they're integrated not only were they
integrated ethnically and skin color but
they were also integrated with all of
the different traditions of
Christianity's that everybody's got to
be at the table and he put Catholics and
Calvinist on the stage and he put
Protestants and Pentecostals and he put
you know charismatic and evangelicals
and fundamentals and they were all there
and some people got mad at that but he
said I'm not coming unless there's a
unity and of course in in politics one
of the things he taught me was that
you've got to Shepherd everybody that
you have friends who were Republicans
friends are Democrats and for them all
you don't get co-opted by any particular
partisan group because he has to be
above the fray and that's why he did for
instance you know pray and counsel and
and share with time unfortunately we
could we can do an hour on this I want
to have Pat and Rick and Jillian back on
radio I hope as soon as possible to
discuss this legacy we could do an hour
on it thank you gentlemen so much